happy fourth of them Father's Day sorry
guys a blooper reels this have always
the best man happy fourth of July
hey guys I'm avi shart welcome to Abby's
kitchen and I'm back in the kitchen with
my friend Davina from the healthy maven
hi guys
so we are gonna be celebrating the 4th
of July to Canadian girls who love their
red white and blue and we've got two
amazing vegan dessert recipes that you
are going to love and they're super easy
too so you don't get stuck in the
kitchen on 4th of July when you should
be outside a little somethin should we
jump in let's do this we are gonna be
making a vegan watermelon cake oh that
sounds fun
and really fun really refreshing super
healthy and light we are going to cut
this bad boy up so bottom and top off
first of course now this is where things
get technical but basically what we're
gonna do is try to get some of the rind
off
if you want a little snack I think
actually yeah I could snack oh but why
don't really go wah wah so alright looks
pretty good that looks good
so now we're gonna make the vegan icing
so this starts with some up coconut
yogurt and if you don't want to make
this vegan totally use whatever yogurt
you've got regular yogurt is totally
yeah I'm gonna add in some unsweetened
coconut it's a great binder
it adds delicious flavor I love that
kind of like feels like it's time for a
holiday when you know let's just
celebrate that's just celebrate the
let's start the front all right not bad
whatever and they spin their on top you
want to spread them yes I would love to
spice and thin surprisingly thin we
don't win oh you think because if it
gets too thick then it gets sloppy and
then you don't want to do I don't want
it to be this kind of fall off I know
it's gonna like a little messy but don't
worry this is a fun thing to get the kid
office right and I and that's why you
throw things on top of and you totally
do you can't cover all this up if you're
not gonna see any of the boo-boos all
right look not good she looks all iced
up and now it's the fun part we actually
get to decorate it so this is like the
red white blue coming to life yes
all right show me how you do this I'm
gonna do like a little crown of
blueberries no I'm certified uh-huh
all right party back alright let's go in
with some red so I'm thinking like some
kind of like Oh little guys like that
perfect strawberries fresh also in
season diamond tread some raspberries
because I love these too
man that looks good I have an idea let's
put some raspberries right around the
edge down perfect well you can shut
those pair of batteries I'm gonna do a
layer of bananas yeah we probably think
we're gonna throw some coconut on so
we're gonna go with the throwing
technique all right this is super pretty
now we're gonna put a little bit of
sliced almonds as well and could you
substitute like seeds or something if
you're allergic to that 100% perfect
all right let's dig I'm so excited to
watch you cut this it's a very delicate
Rafah let me know if you need an extra
set of hands here that's so good mmm
really good it's really refreshing
really owes well that was so much fun
thanks for coming over to Vita thank you
for having me
great fourth of July little party here
we got going on just meet you and a lot
of desserts I can love it so if you like
what you see of course be sure to
subscribe to the channel leave me a
comment below about what you're gonna be
making for the 4th of July chicken
fajitas recipe over at the healthy maven
and I'll see you next time on Abby's
kitchen red white and blue all over town
okay